well it's a real honor and a pleasure to
introduce Susan linguists to this
audience she obtained her
degree from Harvard University although
we don't hold that against her and she
was Alaska professor of the medical
science at the University of before she
moved to the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology in 2001 she's been a member
of the Whitehead Institute there and she
served as director from 2001 to 2004 her
her research focus has been on protein
folding if she's really led this field
into multiple new directions she's shown
that protein conformational changes are
critical in a range of effects cellular
stress evolution transmission of traits
and most recently nerded generation
which i think is going to be the focus
today in one of these lines of work in
terms of the role in phenotypic
variation and evolution she shows
specifically that hsp90 can buffer
silent polymorphisms and when that
function is lost
these can be manifest and be selected
and genetic diversity can be
evolutionarily advanced she's also shown
that HSP 40 can be involved in clearing
protein aggregates in terms of
transmission of traits she's also made
groundbreaking discoveries the second
whole line of work there had been the
idea of protein confirmation
transmission of traits but it was dr.
linked with studies that really using
yeast genetics that brought this home
and provided the most convincing
evidence that protein confirmations can
transform without nucleic acids finally
in the last decade she's focused on
neurodegenerative disease which I think
she's going to talk about primarily
today there'd been a lot of evidence
that protein folding matters but how
this affects the cell and how it makes
cell sick hadn't been clear it's her
ability to harness East genetics to
reduce this problem to single cells that
has really made tractable advances and I
think has the promise for the next
century of research making real inroads
in Alzheimer's Parkinson's Beyond she's
won a number of honors Dickson prize the
Otto Warburg prize max delbruck medal
the US
National Medal of Science and she's a
member of the National Academy so let's
welcome Susan Lindquist thank you so
much and I want to thank everyone
involved with this symposium for
inviting me because it's just been
absolutely fantastic and I want to thank
the previous speakers for a wonderful
set of talks so I work on a variety of
different problems involving protein
folding and we haven't given up date
just be 90 or pry on stuff yes even
though we've started this and basically
the the problem of protein folding is
that every protein has to fold into
these incredibly complicated very very
specific structures and each protein
folds into a different structure and
they have to do that in an environment
that's just absolutely absurd yeah they
have to do that inside of a living cell
and the reason why it's absurd is that
the concentration of other proteins in
that cell is just staggering it's about
300 milligrams per mil it's about the
same concentration is concentrations of
proteins and packed crystals that
crystallographer is used to study
structures but of course the proteins
inside of a living cell are not static
they're moving around at actually
incredible speeds they're bumping into
each other all the time
and so getting a protein an extended
polypeptide chain folded properly and
and maintaining those folds when they're
colliding with each other with
incredible kinetic energy is really very
very difficult difficult problem and so
when you think about proteins going
about their business inside of a living
cell it's very much not like Esther
Williams and her roommates
it's much more like the wave pool at the
Summerland amusement park and a really
hot summer day
so just imagine if if a little bit more
kinetic energy were put into that system
for example with the heat shock or a
little bit of the water was taken out of
that system for example with an
asthmatic stress or if some of the
individuals in that that sea we're not
really as strongly structured as other
individuals you can imagine it would
lead to a crisis in a hurry and in fact
that's happening in cells all the time
living systems are poised and a protein
folding crisis and the reason why they
do that is that there's there's
tremendous efficiencies to be gained
from having proteins so closely packed
together you can pass electrons from one
protein to another but they pay a very
high price for that because there's
there's constantly this danger of
proteins going off pathway and protein
misfolding and in fact we now understand
that many many human diseases are caused
by problems in protein misfolding and
thinking about them that way it might
provide a line of attack for us and so
we've been studying this protein folding
problem for quite a long time and
finally decided that well maybe we ought
to tackle some of the human protein
folding diseases and these are just some
of the diseases that that involve
protein is fold and these happen to all
bener degenerative diseases things like
frontal temporal dimension ALS
Parkinson's disease Huntington's
Alzheimer's prion diseases and they're
all caused by the Mist folding or appear
to be caused by the mis folding of
different individual proteins in these
different diseases and so because we
started to learn quite a bit about
protein folding we thought well maybe we
should try to tackle these because the
devastation that these miss folding
processes brought in living human brain
is just staggering it's it's any of you
who this picture speaks for itself but
I'm sure most of you who have met or
encountered people with this disease
or had the misfortune of having your
loved ones suffer from it will
understand why we really need to tackle
the disease and especially as our
population is getting older and older
perhaps I especially wanted to look at
it as I started to got to play myself
getting older and older I really wanted
to think that maybe we could we could
start working on this and the idea was
to try using yeast cells these are
typical yeast cells they're budding
yeast Saccharomyces cerevisiae
as a sort of a living test tube to study
these complicated protein folding
problems and if your attitude is like
these folks here you're you're not alone
because this is very much the aptitude
we face when we first proposed this at a
very very very hard time getting any
funding for this I had a hard time
getting anyone to work on it in my
laboratory
but as Mike today's made a statement to
encourage people to continue working in
the face of otherwise discouraging
events the the student who tackled this
has really first started tagless in my
lab and has now led to many other people
who've been willing to take it on has
actually found that in fact when we take
these proteins into a yeast cell they
miss fold and they're toxic but they
don't just cause a nonspecific
generalized protein aggregation toxicity
in fact the kinds of toxicities we get
for each of these proteins is very
specific for each of those proteins and
it depends upon where that protein is
miss folding and what other types of
proteins it's interacting with when it
miss folds the things we find in these
yeast models of neural neural
pathological processes actually both
genetics and compounds that we find
matter to neurons that are suffering
from the miss folding of these same
proteins and in very specific ways and
in fact connect up with all sorts of
aspects of human diseases both in terms
of the toxins the nature of the toxins
that can be associated with these
neurodegenerative disease
and the human disease alleles that are
associated with these diseases so the
reason of course for doing anything in
the yeast cell is one there's two and
one of them is that these cells are
eukaryotic cells neurons are two neurons
are very very fancy eukaryotic cells but
they're eukaryotic cells and all of
these things are very very highly
conserved in yeast and in neurons
lipid biology vesicle trafficking and
fusion and the ways in which that's
regulated lysosomes and peroxisomes auto
Figgy apoptosis complicated cell cycle
mitochondria and oxidative stress and of
course a whole realm of proteins that
are involved in taking care of that
problem I told you about the protein
folding problem and the cell actually
devotes about 5% of total protein in the
cell to taking care of this problem and
it involves chaperones it involves
proteasome that involves ubiquitin
ligases it involves auto [ __ ] and
osmolytes and all sorts of all sorts of
mechanisms anyway these are very very
highly conserved from yeast cells to
neurons and the other reason for wanting
to work with yeast is that it has an
absolutely unrivaled toolkit I mean
there's a lot of great things we can do
with mice now and nematodes and fruit
flies but believe me there is no
organism on the planet we can manipulate
as well as fasoli as we can
yeast cells and in fact the amount of
information we have on protein protein
interactions and genetic interactions is
unrivaled and furthermore there's single
cells now that may seem like a really
crazy thing to think of as an advantage
when studying in neurological pathology
but I'll tell you why I think it's a
very big advantage neurons are talking
to each other and are talking to glial
cells and their support systems all the
time it's talk talk talk talk talk and
their interests and their interactions
with each other are profoundly
influencing them and so if you want to
try to actually study the fundamental
underlying process that's responsible
for these diseases and we have no
therapies not one currently
aimed at the fundamental underlying
problems that are going wrong with these
proteins um if you want to try to study
that it would be nice maybe to isolate
all of the complexities of these
interactions with other proteins and
other sorry other neurons and other cell
types and just really look at the
problem of that particular protein in an
individual isolate itself so I'm gonna
start I'm gonna tell you about two of
these pathologies that we've been
looking at one is involved with
synuclein and the other is a beta the
significant work we've published most of
although we have a lot more stuff I'm
not going to tell you about that we can
that hasn't published but the the a beta
story has been submitted but not yet
published so the significant apathy is
are varied Parkinson's disease dementia
with Lewy bodies and multiple systems
atrophy and they're all characterized
when you slice through a brain as I
showed you those sections of pathologist
slides earlier those brown blobs that
were protein aggregates well these
nuclei and aggregates can occur in
different cell types and when they
curtain different cell types they're
associated with different diseases but
certainly the one that we know the most
about and the one that is the most
common is Parkinson's disease and
preferences is really a spectrum of
disorders it's the second most common
neurodegenerative disorder and it's
particularly characterized by the loss
particulars of dopaminergic neurons
which lead to severe motor defects and
and more but it's now appreciated that
the pathology is moved is broader than
just the dopaminergic neurons it's been
a will drink it's a very complex in
building disease because there are a lot
of associations with environmental
toxins such as for example manganese
miners of the metal manganese get-get PD
twice as often as miners of other metals
and drug recreational drug users where
the manganese is contaminated the drugs
have have gotten the disease
and there's also a variety of
mitochondrial poisons that are
associated with with PD or at least
parkinsonism and then there are many
different genetic factors that
contribute these are called par close
eye and they're being elaborated more
and more all the time and many of these
diseases even though they're associated
with different genetic lesions when
people go to autopsy they see Lewy
bodies or their self-esteem nuclear an
aggregation not not by any means in all
of them however and finally park1 the
first parkinsonism allele is a protein
called alpha synuclein which is in those
aggregates and it was also found that
mutation of alpha synuclein
or ample amplification of the wild-type
protein is sufficient to cause early
onset parkinson's now these are this one
is relatively rare cause of PD this one
is not so rare but still the very fact
that this particular protein is
aggregated in these diseases in this
disease with all these different
environmental and genetic causes and the
simple overexpression of that wild-type
protein is sufficient to cause the
disease in humans made us think that
would might be worth trying to over
express that protein in the East I don't
see what happened and we were encouraged
by another thing with regard to trying
this and that is that alpha synuclein is
a very simple little protein it's not
that like the lerk kinase which some of
you may know is also involved with PD
which is a very complicated multi domain
protein alpha-synuclein is 14 kill adult
little tiny protein that folds into four
alpha helixes it associates with
phospholipids and membranes and when
it's not associated with membranes it's
prone to its natively unfolded and it's
prone to forming Olga MERS and larger
polymers and these are believed to be
the toxic species and especially older
Mabo don't take this structure as being
serious it's just an imaginary structure
but the ollague mirac forms of the
protein
that accumulate when the natively folded
protein is not associated with membrane
are believed to be part of the toxicity
so we put alpha synuclein stitched up to
a green fluorescent protein and a very
easily regulated promoter in yeast so we
can normally keep it off and turn it on
whenever you want to and when we put in
two copies of that gene in the yeast
cell it goes to the plasma membrane and
that's great that was just it's what we
expected it to do because in human
neurons it's localized to vesicles at
the ends of synapses and one difference
between yeast and neurons and there are
I will admit quite a few is that in
yeast cells secretion process is
constitutive so if alpha synuclein was
getting into secretory vesicles in a
yeast cell what we would expect it to do
is just wind up on the plasma membrane
so if we express a little bit more alpha
synuclein or a little bit more alpha
synuclein localization of the protein
changes profoundly and the viability of
the cells changes profoundly so these
cells grow perfectly normally these
cells grow slowly and these cells die
and so that provides us very immediately
with a platform for doing genetic
screens and in collaboration with Josh
libéré who did almost all of the work we
just help them finish making a library
of the yeast genome that contains every
open reading frame of the yeast genome
under the control of the same promoter
that we use to induce alpha synuclein
and we like this library a little bit
better many of you may be familiar with
the yeast deletion library and that's a
great that's been a great system too but
the yeast Elysion library is a bunch of
strains that have been coping with
deletions of various proteins for a long
time and all kinds of changes have taken
place in those cells with this
overexpression library of what happens
is we transform a cell that has a
moderately toxic level of alpha
synuclein with each one of these
plasmids
assemble a library of strains that kid
tables different plasmas and then we
husband among glucose so the cells
aren't experiencing anything any change
and only when we transfer them to
galactose does the alpha synuclein gene
and the other gene turn out at the same
time and so we can test how very cleanly
how that gene modifies the toxicity of
alpha synuclein looking for either
enhancers or suppressors and so more
recently we've gotten robots that allow
us to do this much more efficiently and
this is how our current screens are
looking these are robots that have
printed our various yeast strains onto
media and these cells are not induced
and they're growing just fine these
cells are induced and they're growing
more slowly and what you'll see is
they're groups of four here and that's
because we test every gene four times
and it gives us much more reliable
results so we've print every single all
four of these strains contain the same
test plasmid all four of these strains
contain the same test plasmids and this
is clearly enhanced enhancer of toxicity
makes things worse and this is a
suppressor of toxicity so then of course
the things we get out we have to test in
a neuronal system and we have tested
them in three different systems we've
tested them in C elegans in
collaboration with guy Caldwell in
Drosophila with in collaboration with
Nancy Benigni and in primary rat
embryonic mid brain cultures in
collaboration with Chris Roche although
we now have this up and running in my
own lab and we are beginning what I
think is going to be a very exciting
collaboration with Rudolf jaenisch
to translate our things into human iPS
cells derived from patients because
these disease are very complicated there
are a lot of different underlying
genetic factors and I think for any G's
gene disease that's going to need
personalized medicine I think this is a
real poster child anyway do our genes
that we got out of a yeast cell that
have conserved Homan homologs actually
matter to her neuron expressing alpha
synuclein
and so I'm just gonna tell you that the
very first Jean we got out that that
that had a very strong effect was a
rabjeet epa's that's involved in
controlling vesicle trafficking and it
controls vesicle trafficking from the
Golgi to the ER and is a very closely
related rabjeet epa's that in neurons
with neurons have more of these things
than you cells do that a neuron c-can't
rolls vesicle trafficking if in the
synapse and so I'm gonna just tell you
that this Rab one worked in nematodes
and it worked in fruit flies I'll just
show you the results with red primary
cortical not primary primary
dopaminergic neurons neurons from the
midbrain region of the embryonic rat
that were put into culture and we get a
rough sense of how many dopaminergic
neurons there are in these cultures by
staining with th and in these cultures
we typically get about 7% of the neurons
are dopaminergic neurons and when we
express alpha synuclein and here we're
expressing a mutant that's associated
with early onset PD it kills actually
lots of the neurons in look in the
culture but it kills the dopaminergic
neurons even more frequently than it
kills other neurons and so the
percentage of the dopaminergic neurons
goes down if we co express Lac see with
that it has no effect but if we co
express that Rab 1gt pas it has a pretty
strong rescuing effect in these neurons
as well as it did in yeast we also see
changes in vesicle trafficking and in
fact subsequent experiments I'll show
you we we find that we can directly
assess the effects of alpha-synuclein on
vesicle trafficking so we've done this
now with nine different genes which have
very diverse functions so functions that
you wouldn't necessarily think would be
connected but they're clearly connected
because they modulate the toxicity
that's caused by overexpressing alpha
synuclein
and eight out of those nine genes that
we tested from our yeast screen and
tested in the neuronal system have
worked
so I mentioned that vesicle trafficking
seemed to be particularly sensitive and
in fact when we looked at our yeast
cells that were accumulating
alpha-synuclein and where it was
accumulating in a toxic state we started
to see vesicles being blocked but from
there were Nets fusing with the target
membranes and Virginia Lee actually has
done autopsies on human patients with PD
now and she's seen that in fact Lewy
bodies are associated with a lot of
traffic vesicles so what does alpha
synuclein do in vesicle trafficking well
Charlie about Barlow has this wonderful
asset but she isolates ER and he can
examine vesicle budding and in the
addition of cellular factors he can
examine docking infusion by the fact
that when the vesicles dock they get the
proteins get modified and so we
collaborated with Charlie and found that
in fact what Elfa synuclein does is it
doesn't interfere with vesicle budding
at all in fact if anything it stimulates
it but when it comes to vesicle fusion
with a target membrane it completely
blocks it and in fact alpha synuclein is
associated with that focus of blocked
vesicles when I showed you in those
earlier cells those big kind of green
bowling balls of gfp labeled alpha
synuclein when you look at those by
electron microscopy they're black
vesicles with high concentrations of
alpha synuclein surrounding them so
alpha synuclein causes problems
specifically in vesicle trafficking and
at specific stages of vesicle
trafficking we've also found one of the
genes that we found that suppresses the
alpha synuclein tax the city was
annotated in the yeast genome is being
yeast open reading frame 291 w not very
informative because nobody even in yeast
knew what this was doing but it was of
interest to us because we found that it
has very very highly homologous to a
human protein and moreover about six
months after we found it in yeast this
paper was published it published that
hereditary parkinsonism with dementia is
caused by mutations in that protein and
it encodes the lysosomal protein that's
a p-type ATPase so it's at the lysosome
it's in a diff
place from the alpha-synuclein the cell
and there would have been no reason from
the human data to connect it up with
alpha synuclein toxicity but we find it
as a suppressor when we overexpress this
function we find a suppressor self
sniffing toxicity we're able then and
now spare you the details were able then
to find that this protein what it's
doing is it's a p-type ATP's and what
it's doing is its pumping manganese and
it pumps manganese into the vacuole to
get to reduce the cellular
concentrations of manganese this is very
interesting because remember I told you
earlier that there's been associations
between manganese toxicity and
parkinsonism and interestingly we had 60
metal ion transporters in our screen we
got out three metal ion transporters and
suppressing elf or it entered one was an
enhancer one tumor suppressors of
alpha-synuclein facticity all three of
them are manganese transporters one of
them transports Banga DS and calcium
into the ER and affects Golgi
trafficking and another one of them
affects transports manganese and iron
and all three of those metals have had
very interesting history of associations
with parkinsonism our micro arrays also
told us that there's a lot of
mitochondrial damage and that
alpha-synuclein accumulation in these
Eggers is causing bursts of reactive
oxygen species so we then did a chemical
library the screen for things that would
suppress and what we did was we screen
150,000 compounds over at the harvard
ICCB
and we asked in this case for
restoration of toxicity and that really
high toxicities sorry amelioration of
toxicity and that really high toxicity
strain not the intermediate texas of
these during which we screened
genetically because genetically we
obviously found it was very complex
we're finding all sorts of different
things going wrong and so we wondered if
in the higher taxes that he strained
when lots and lots of things are going
wrong mitochondrial texas all sorts of
things are happening would it be
possible to find a compound that would
rescue against that it was a very
rigorous rigorous screen a high bar to
pass we found some compound
that did we went that back and looked at
vesicle trafficking and it turned out
that they fix vesicle trafficking they
also fix the mitochondrial defects and
they work in the nematode and they work
in wrapped neurons in culture too so
this is an example of a test done in
nematodes and it's actually not easy to
get drugs into these little beasts they
live out in the soil and they have lots
of drug pumps and so you have to do
things like dissolve the drugs in DMSO
and kinds of yucky things but you can do
it and basically what we have here is
we've got alpha synuclein being
expressed in the dopaminergic neurons of
nematodes nematodes don't have a very
sophisticated nervous system but what
they have is dopaminergic neurons and
they always invariably have exactly the
same number of dopaminergic neurons in
exactly the same position and so in this
particular view the we always see four
dopaminergic neurons and wild-type
animals when they're expressing alpha
synuclein some of the neurons die some
of them just there don't extend their
processes actually this is an
age-related phenomena so they actually
start out looking good but then they
regress and if we treat the worms with
one of the compounds we've got our yeast
screen the neurons get better and
finally we were able to take as I
mentioned there are mitochondrial
poisons that kill neurons and ways that
are believed to be very closely related
to parkinsonism and in fact you can
create diseases and animal models with
these kinds of compounds and in fact
humans who have accidentally encountered
these compounds can get Parkinson's
disease and these are mitochondrial
poisons and this just simply shows you
that a dish of neurons that looks like
hell because it's been exposed to one of
these mitochondrial poisons and this is
what these neurons look like when
they've been exposed to mitochondrial
poison in the presence of our compound
which we got out solely by its ability
to rescue yeast cells from
alpha-synuclein
so I think the fact that we're able to
get out both genes and compounds that
matter to neurons
in a matter to the toxicity of
alpha-synuclein a neurons indicates that
what's it's not that alpha synuclein is
killing dopaminergic neurons because
there's some something completely unique
to those dopaminergic neurons you don't
have to only study the death Allah Jie
process in a neuron that it's actually
alpha Sufi is causing some fundamental
process that's interfacing with very
very conserved basic aspects of
eukaryotic cell biology and the question
then is really why does it hit
dopaminergic neurons what are the
special vulnerabilities that make
dopaminergic neurons particularly
sensitive to this general pathology and
I think that there are many of them and
we're only beginning to understand it
but certainly of course neurons are very
very highly dependent upon vesicle
trafficking especially if
neurotransmitters the foci of
alpha-synuclein
at least we find in a yeast cell seems
to lead to a very high local
concentration when those vesicles get
blacked the protein comes on and off the
membranes and then you start to form
toxic all of America species which do
other other types of damage to the cells
there's some special vulnerability to
metal ions which we don't yet understand
but what we can say is it's related to
then the MIS function of alpha-synuclein
neurons have very very high rates of
respiration very very dependent upon
mitochondria especially dopaminergic
neurons and finally dopamine is in
particular a particularly dangerous
neurotransmitter because it's made out
in the cytoplasm and it needs to be
pumped into vesicles to prevent it from
becoming toxic and just decaying and
causing all kinds of reactive oxygen
species and in fact so if you have a
defect in the production of vesicles
than the forward trafficking of
secretory vesicles a dopaminergic neuron
would be more sensitive than many
neurons to that process so I'm not going
to turn to something different I'd like
to tell you about what we've been doing
with a beta toxicity
but before I do I'm gonna first have a
very brief foray into prints and you'll
see why because there's a relationship
between prions and a beta that I think
is important so Eric talked about prions
yesterday I understand and this is an
animal suffering from the prion disease
known as scrapey it's a disease that's
caused by the Mis folding of a protein
the protein is actually the infectious
agent in the disease it miss folds and
causes other proteins of the same type
to miss fold too and that can be spread
as an infectious agent turns out that
yeast cells have prions as well and
we've my lab has worked quite a bit on
these these red cells and these white
cells are genetically absolutely
identical the difference between them is
that these white cells have one
particular protein in an altered prion
conformation and that alteration and
protein folding is self-perpetuating
it's self templating and self
perpetuating and so it actually serves
as an element of genetic inheritance
these cells inherit this in a very very
orderly way and there are actually
systems the reason I got into this is
because the protein I've been working on
called hsp104 is actually a device
that's employed to partition these
aggregates into daughter cells and make
sure that the cells inherited in a very
orderly way now this doesn't just change
cells from red to white it creates all
kinds of wonderful phenotypes in these
cells and does all kinds of interesting
things we actually have found 25 prions
in yeast and I know Eric conveyed you to
you the message that prions can be great
they're not just terrible and we think
prions are great in yeast and i'm not
going to go into any of that I'm just
mentioning prions for one reason
these are little foci of prion
aggregates that are you can see being
inherited by the mother cells to the
daughters and what those folks I really
are is amyloid fibers and of course
amyloids figure heavily and all of these
different neurodegenerative disease
and we found that if we could purify
this protein in the soluble form it
would assemble in a test tube
slowly very inefficiently but if we took
a very small bit of the preassembled
protein and edited to the start of a new
reaction it would do that
so the ability of this protein amyloid
to self template itself is extremely
extremely efficient and that's what
allows you to have these two different
states it's hard for the protein to get
into the amyloid state so mostly it's
soluble but when it gets into the
amyloid state that stays in that state
and gets passed on and inherited well
very early on years ago we found that
there was a very odd mechanism of
polymerization for this protein it
assembles into an old Americ species a
molten america species it's a natively
unfolded protein rather like alpha
synuclein if you purify the protein and
put it into physiological buffer it's
natively unfolded forms these molten old
america species and they then assemble
into amyloids and shortly after we
published that paper it was descriptive
the fact that a beta assembles in a very
similar way was described and then
Charlie Glade did something amazing he
made an antibody against the old america
form of a beta that does not recognize
the monomer or the amyloid it recognizes
something about the conformation of the
old man and oddly enough it recognizes
something about the conformation of
older more experienced in oakland and
several other proteins that are
associated with neurodegenerative
disease there's some common confirmation
in this old dimeric species which many
people now are beginning to believe is
really the most toxic form and all of
these diseases and I call it Charlie's
magic antibody because if you take
reactions out of our yeast assembly at
various times this yeast prion which has
not anything even remotely related in
sequence to the a beta protein that
antibody does not recognize the monomers
it recognizes an old america species
that has begins to assemble and very
quickly converts to amyloid and the
antibody
longer recognizes the amyloid so there
is something about the confirmations of
these proteins that are natively
unfolded and can get into amyloids
where where they dwell in a cat and an
old america she's that has some
mysterious property that's that's common
amongst them so why aren't the Easton
woods that I'm telling you about I'm
telling you pre ends are good in this
rant they're toxic the reason is because
they very efficiently assemble into
amyloid and in fact if we books I'm
supposed to be talking now it looks like
the very efficient assemble enamel is if
we do things that cause them not to
assemble very well they become very
toxic so the basic message then is that
this this problem protein folding is as
ancient as the hills these same types of
must folding forms accumulate in yeast
cells as well as in higher neurons and
so it might seem reasonably not so
unreasonable that we could maybe take a
look at the toxicity and the things that
affect the toxicity of a beta in Aggie
cells so how do we do that well many of
you I'm sure know that a beta is
actually made from a much larger
precursor protein called a PP that
appears first of course in the
endoplasmic reticulum and then traffic
so the Golgi goes into various secretory
vesicles winds up being secreted from
the cell a beta can be secreted the AP
peak in this unprocessed form can come
back in and be endocytosed a beta can be
generated in an acidic compartments and
in the lysosome it's very complicated
trafficking and no one really knows
quite where all of the toxic stuff is
although certainly stuff out in the
plasma membrane matters a lot so how do
we replicate this in a yeast cell we
don't want to deal with the processing
of a PP so what we do is we take a beta
and put a secretory signal on it so that
gets a beta expressed in the ER and then
it gets cleaved and it has no retention
signal on it
so it will start to migrate to the Golgi
it will go to secretory vesicles it will
get out to the plasma membrane and
here's an extra advantage of the yeast
cells they've got a cell wall so that
keeps the a beta local it keeps it at a
high local concentration to the plasma
membrane and it doesn't just float away
and that allows it to come back in by
endocytosis and appear in various
compartments of this this very vast
secretory compartments of the cell so we
do a unbiased screen of 6000 yeast genes
for things that modify toxicity and
these are the genes that we found that
have high very close human homologues we
find 3 genes involved in
clathrin-mediated endocytosis very
interestingly this gene here is the
third highest hit on the human genome
wide arrays four alleles associated with
a risk of Alzheimer's disease it's been
replicated in 11 different genome-wide
arrays studies in both sporadic and
familial ad this gene right here there's
a new study of Alzheimer's disease
alleles which popped out two additional
genes involved in endocytosis and this
gene right here is the direct partner
protein of one of those other jeans
which polymorphisms are associated with
early onset AD in people and we have
also unpublished two actually there's a
total now of five different genes in
this gene list that looked like they
might be associated polymorphisms are
associated with early onset Alzheimer's
disease some of them are still a little
bit iffy but three of them are pretty
damn good so we created to see whether
or not we could duplicate the effects of
these genes in a glutamatergic neuron
no no cell type that's related to AD we
expressed a beta in the glutamatergic
neurons of the nematode and what you see
here we've marked them with GFP and you
see a certain
neurons all the time in those worms but
when they're expressing a beta you see
fewer of those neurons and it's an
age-related thing so at 3 days about
only about 50% of the worms have the
normal number of neurons at 7 days only
about 30% of the normal number of
age-related decline and if we co express
MJ or lac see nothing happens but if we
co express our endocytosis suppressors
they suppress Rico Express 3 other
unrelated suppressors and different
pathways two of which are have
connections with human genome wide
arrays they suppress and if we express
an enhancer it enhances so every gene
we've tested in the nematode affects the
toxicity of a beta and these little
matured neurons in the same way as it
does in yeast finally we went to rat
cortical neurons there there aren't very
good models for studying a beta toxicity
but one of the things that people do is
they assemble the a beta and oligomers
and stick them on to neurons and neurons
seem to be dying in ways that might be
related to AD there has been actually
been many very good demonstrations of
that but at least one gene April II has
been demonstrated to affect the toxicity
of a beta applied in this way and now we
find that if cells are exposed to
vehicle alone with GF P or P column
there's no difference but if we expose
them to a beta Olga MERS the Court of
Honor ons are drastically affected and
GFP has no effect but P calm rescues and
dosage dependent manner so P calm has
been although it's been very very highly
validated and the assuming G while
arrays for Alzheimer's disease it's been
thought to actually work by effects and
since it's a gene involved in
endocytosis has been thought to work by
affecting the prot the trafficking of a
PP but we're not expressing a PP we're
expressing a beta so we as we show here
it's directly involved in modifying the
toxicity of a beta in a yeast cell and
in a neuron so now we can return to
sells and actually asks what what's the
mechanism there's two obvious things you
can think about one is it could just be
that and the stuff is on the plasma
membrane that's bad
you want to endocytosis and dump dump it
into the lysosome or the vacuole to get
rid of it so you want to upregulate it
into psychosis that's interesting but
it's not not terribly sophisticated but
what if instead it might be that a beta
actually is specifically toxic to the
unde acidic machinery and the reason why
you need to upregulate
endocytosis is to cope with a primary
toxicity induced by a beta so to look at
that we looked at a membrane receptor
that's normally involved in binding to
mating pheromone on the surface of these
cells and in the absence of mating
pheromone endocytosis takes it and dumps
it into the vacuole and you can see that
when you tag it with gfp what happens
when you express a beta the vacuolar
trafficking of this receptor membrane
plasma membrane receptor is profoundly
disturbed our modifiers restore not
completely but restore significantly the
trafficking of that receptor and then
interestingly these two genes should be
working in rather different ways they
both work on calf and mediate
endocytosis but one of them is involved
in increasing the production of
clathrin-mediated vesicles and the other
is involved in getting those faster
mediated vesicles to the next target the
target membrane and uncoated and in fact
when we look at cells in which we've
monitoring the clathrin clathrin itself
we see that a beta screws up clathrin
trafficking and the one one of the
receptors one of the modifiers fixes
that trafficking defect by increasing
the amount of fat from media coated
vesicles and the other one increases the
flow to that pathway by increasing the
uncoding of the vesicles anyway this is
just to finish up very very quickly now
we've screened hundred and twenty
thousand compounds for things that will
restore viability the yeast cells
expressing a beta and we have gotten
quite a few moderate strength
suppressors a few go as high as rescuing
50 percent of cell growth several of
them also work in the nematode to rescue
from the glutamatergic neuron induced
cell death of a beta one works in a
mouse ad model and restores both reduces
pathology and restores cognition and we
haven't done that work actually it turns
out that our yeast screeners hit a
compound that the laboratory of Ashley
Bush and Rudy tansy have been working on
as actually currently in clinical trials
it's actually the only thing currently
in clinical trials that is believed to
modify the toxicity of a beta itself and
it's a account from the it's got a long
history of toxic effects and all sorts
of other things I don't think it has a
lot of legs on it in the long term
because in fact also in our yeast cells
it it rescues these cells quite nicely
but it's a very delicate balance in the
and how much of it you add because well
then then cause cell death but we have a
few compounds that actually have a
fairly broad range where we can suppress
toxicity and add the tenfold higher
concentrations and they don't cause
toxicity so I'm hoping that this is just
the tip of the iceberg I really think
that being able to use yeast model
systems and platforms for discovery for
doing high throughput analyses and then
going back to neurons and then taking
things from neurons and bringing them
back to use and trying to figure out how
they might work could be used and
applied to a variety of other of these
protein misfolding diseases and I'd like
very very especially to thank the
students and postdocs in my laboratory
who did all of this work and especially
and I had a wonderful wonderful
wonderful group of people in my
laboratory especially thank jaga Lootera
who tackled the alpha-synuclein project
when not only does everybody from
outside labs telling us we were crazy
but the people in my own lab were
telling him he was crazy what that
brilliant [ __ ] and Anil Kasia Karan
and Aaron get lured did all of the
high-throughput screening
model Julius sue worked on the compounds
and these folks worked on other aspects
of the project that I haven't told you
about these are the folks that are
working on the a beta modeling yeast and
this is our amazing wonderful wonderful
group of collaborators without whose
help we really couldn't be where we are
so I'd like to thank you again for
listening